thank you
it's possible that until the countdown
hits zero it doesn't link up
so JJ I was thinking potentially I let
you go first and kind of just like State
your position and I stayed like my
position and then we kind of go back and
forth from there so that sounds sensible
to you
that's great
thanks again for doing this oh thank you
like uh thank you like seriously I want
to say that live as well I want to
encourage this kind to pay way more I
think this is super super productive
let's have you know like people just
dunk each other on Twitter I'd much
rather people just have discussions
about things and just like be open to
you know being wrong
totally agree yeah so yeah sure yeah for
sure it's gonna be fun I think so too I
I know for sure I'm going to learn some
things so yeah yeah it'll be fun
whatever happens it'll be a good time
yeah I'm looking forward to it yeah
oh okay so I can I can see the feed but
are we live on YouTube that's the
question
should I open YouTube separately or
should I I just have the Riverside tab
open on my side I just kind of closed
everything else yeah perhaps if someone
on YouTube can just say it doesn't seem
to be live yeah so we're definitely
feeding into YouTube so maybe I just
need to do something
I'm in the YouTube dashboard oh it's
live people are saying it's live okay in
which case we'll go on so we're a little
bit short on time we've got exactly one
hour so I'm just going to do a quick
introduction so um kanalihi is an AI
researcher working on understanding
large ml models and aligning them to
human values he was a co-founder of a
lighter Ai and is now the CEO of
conjecture which is a team of
researchers dedicated to applied and
scalable AI alignment research Connor
believes that transformative artificial
intelligence will happen in our lifetime
he also believes that powerful Advanced
AI will be derived from modern machine
learning architectures and techniques
such as gradient descent Connor is
currently the main spokesman in my
opinion for the AI alignment movement
and even though I personally disagree
with Connor on AI risk I think he's a
thoroughly decent bloke he's achieved
legendary status in the communities good
mate of mine and I'm very excited for
this discussion today and also Joseph
Jacks founded OSS capital and they are
the world's first and only early stage
VC fund and focusing on Commercial open
source startups so it's an honor as well
Joseph to have you on the show today now
we're going to be discussing
um a debate on AGI is it existential or
is it non-existential Joseph will argue
for open source AGI and why he believes
that it will not pose an existential
threat to humanity
any differently than Humanity itself
already poses an existential threat to
humanity and Connolly he will argue for
not building AGI and why he believes
that it will absolutely pose an
existential threat to humanity now
Joseph and Connor have asked to
self-moderate in this discussion so I'm
going to bow out from here but I really
hope you folks enjoy today's
conversation so with that I'm going to
pass the Baton over to you Connor to
make starting statements and have a good
time thanks yeah thanks Tim I want to
just like say thank you to JJ for
agreeing with us this was his idea and
you know we have disagreements on this
topic and I just think this is really
great that we both get the opportunity
to just kind of like respectfully you
know talk about this as to adults seeing
where we agree or we disagree so really
thank you so much for taking the time to
do this really enjoy it I look forward
to hearing your points and hearing mine
the goal for this discussion as we said
before I think shouldn't be to like
persuade the other person per se to
stero competing it's clearly
see where we agree disagree maybe learn
something from it so yeah thanks for
thanks for doing this and I'd like to
offer you the chance to start us off
with uh your position first if you'd
like
thank you Connor and uh yeah I'm really
grateful for your
open uh openness to doing this as well
um you know we've we've interacted a lot
on Twitter over the over the years and
um I'm a fan of your your work as well
like Tim said I have a lot of respect
for your uh your research and points of
view probably spent you know upwards of
five plus hours of my life listening to
you on on podcasts over over uh you know
maybe more recent history you've been
more more active
um online so I'm grateful for that as
well
yeah I guess the the Crux of uh kind of
reaching out to you is that I do uh you
know sort of deeply disagree with the
view that
um
the sort of materialization of AGI uh so
you know it's probably worth you know
roughly defining that for the listener
um uh you know I don't think we have
Universal industry or human consensus on
what ATI even really means which is
actually quite an important piece to any
discussion uh when you when you talk
about uh you know believing one thing or
another you have to actually have some
consensus on what you're actually
talking about
um but um I don't believe that AGI and
the sort of like most common uh uh sense
of of the definitions that get thrown
out represents an exercise threat to
humanity in in as what Tim said to kind
of complete that any different than
Humanity itself already poses a threat
um you know to itself right like sort of
tautologically so that's kind of where
I'm coming from
um so in other words sort of said
differently
um it it it it does and it can represent
an existential threat that that to be
clear right so there is actually some
Nuance to this argument I'm I'm
certainly not coming back and saying
like there are absolutely no risks you
know this is not a uh a sort of major uh
development in our you know uh currently
you see that we shouldn't be really
deeply concerned about and worried about
um so that last part is a big reason why
I have a lot of respect for you and a
bunch of other really smart people
working on on um sort of alignment and
policy issues from different
perspectives but I I really just kind of
want to reinforce I do take objection to
the view that
um
uh you know uh which I I feel is under
undergirded by a lot of like
assumptions that when AGI occurs there
will be this really fast which I think
is kind of a reference point that people
often use something is useful very fast
take off and as the takeoff occurs
um the AGI will absolutely you know uh
do whatever uh is possible to you know
completely eliminate and Wipeout you
know all the humans right and and so um
uh I guess that's my point of view I'm
gonna like State why I I I don't I you
know uh uh I'll stop I'll stop there
maybe
I'd love to hear maybe like five minutes
on why you think that uh if that's cool
with you sure
yeah I mean I I think that there's a
bunch of assumptions that are built into
um The View that AGI poses this
existential threat to humanity
specifically very rapidly or sort of
specifically as it propagates quickly
and
um you know within some sort of like
finite or short time frame after that
occurs
um you know humanity is is likely to
experience an Annihilation right like I
mean these are like that's at least my
interpretation of you know the sort of
argument is it's not a sort of like you
know
um there's clusters of people that could
be harmed or sort of classes or sort of
you know a geographies it's all humans
um right so sort of like as a unit and
um I guess I'll try to sort of enumerate
the points on on why I I I don't I don't
think that that risk is you know uh
really uh real or narrative at least in
terms of the concern that people are
espousing you know these days
um it you know I'd say the first one is
I don't think we have any evidence
whatsoever
um to you know point to and and and you
know sort of assess
um uh critically uh that says we have
even
um uncovered any degree of fundamental
intelligence in um you know in digital
Computing
um I think that the the current uh
language models diffusion models all the
different
um AI systems that are coming out which
are fundamentally based on these these
these structures called neural networks
are a new type of information
compression and Discovery I do not think
that they represent intelligence in
terms of like how humans um uh uh you
know think and create and and reason
um I think that there are rough
approximations to some of those things
that you can kind of have longer
philosophical arguments on is like what
constitutes reasoning what constitutes
intelligence uh you know on the edges of
a long tail of the distribution but I
don't think that like any of the current
systems even remotely roughly
approximate actual intelligence and so
when we when we take the leap from
current AI systems are um
likely to reach not only human level
intelligence but superhuman level
intelligence and then from there
actually you know take off rapidly and
kill us all I think that there are just
so many massive assumptions along that
path that um I I I personally believe
have have not been uh tested or
um or proven out in in any concrete way
uh to actually defend that sort of set
of assertions I think the that's that's
like one big kind of aspect to it the
second aspect to it is
just sort of pragmatically you know sort
of like assuming that's actually not an
issue certainly everything I just said
is actually not accurate and we are on
this sort of exponential curve of
um uh you know scaling intelligence and
some of the you know uh evidence points
we have today or artifacts are things
that you can point to and say like yes
that represents reasoning yes that
represents intelligence and now we're
just kind of scaling it further
um I think that another really big
um issue with the argument of you know
AGI when it materializes will wipe us
out is practically how right and and and
I think
um that's kind of another
very weird and uncertain and very blurry
um kind of uh topic that I'm very far
from even remotely being convinced of
and I guess I'll just likely add a few
points here so
um probably the strongest you know maybe
examples of Defending that view would be
like you know uh really uh uh viral
pathogens that that are sort of
um uh designed and and distributed
somehow via AGI or with the help of HEI
and and those those pathogens um
obviously start to spread and um you
know we just went through covet so this
is a pretty visceral example people can
really resonate with that I think that
that uh
that argument requires a lot of human uh
cooperation and uh passivity and and we
you know we we literally have to like
forget all the things that we just
learned through the coveted experience
um uh for that to just you know continue
to
um uh uh you know wipe out more and more
Humanity to the to the extent that like
we're completely
um you know annihilated um you know so I
don't I don't really see that I I was
driving around a couple days ago so I
have a Tesla driver and this is one of
these cars that's kind of connected to
the internet and it has a neural net you
know trying to kind of figure out
self-driving and one thought was sort of
like you know well
I guess if there there's a rogue AGI out
there that you know tries to go out into
the internet and identify you know uh uh
Vehicles carrying humans uh and take
over those vehicles and just you know
kind of steer them off the road or you
know accelerate or break in whatever
dangerous conditions I guess
theoretically if there was enough
coordination
um you know it could could could harm or
maybe kill a lot of the people in those
Vehicles pretty rapidly and I was just
sort of thinking this viscerally in my
head was kind of like okay I've really
got to think critically you know all
this really happened I'm physically in
this car and you know it's connected to
the internet and you know presumably
there's like you know really robust you
know uh human
um uh design CC Plus Code like
preventing the neural net from like
having these different attack factors of
control from like an external model that
would want to like direct it somehow
um but like let's say that didn't exist
in in you know the car could be uh uh
you know taken over by some some some
some autonomous agent somewhere like
even in that scenario and if if you know
one to two million I don't know what the
exact number is you know test the fleet
currently on the roads was completely
compromised uh you know at the same time
or something or maybe maybe gradually
over the course of a couple days
I still find it hard to believe that
that would even represent a serious
existential threat because let's say you
could kill maybe a few thousand people
or tens of thousands of people wow
that's like really horrific and really
horrible it's it's a very far uh cry
from you know massive annihilation of
human species and so I just think like
the uh proximity to massive sort of like
instantaneously connected in terms of
like devices connected to the internet
that could have you know sort of like
AGI systems compromise them
um I think it's like a a a a really kind
of almost like a non-issue
um
you know and I guess like the the final
piece maybe this is a bunch of other
things as well but like would be
um
we don't have embodied
mechanisms yet to really like worry
about it I mean and I go to like the
Westworld you know series
um for this like we're not in a current
reality based reality where there are
autonomous like uh devices uh you know
with enough propagation to go to to go
around and be like one to one paired
with each human living on the planet and
um
uh you know uh go out and and do really
you know sort of very nuanced and
various things even even the current
like Cutting Edge drone technology uh is
still uh I think
um uh is not sophisticated enough to
like
uh identify and come within close enough
proximity to kill every person that
could kill a lot of people and those are
very uh dangerous devices and I think
the the current level of
um Advanced uh drone development is
certainly already there to
um uh make it possible for for for you
know weapons to to be you know extremely
um lethally harmful for many you know uh
uh many humans and perhaps a non not not
insignificant percentage of humanity
um but those are sort of like
I don't know I guess those are like the
top
you know set of arguments that I would
that I would uh put out that that sort
of make me believe this this AGI sort of
threat is not
um is not a real like sort of
existential uh issue and I think it's
um
uh very uh sort of nonsensical to sort
of be as
um uh sort of aggressive and
um you know sort of the term I use is
like fear-mongery I mean maybe that's
too like pejorative or negative of a
termite I I don't mean to be like sort
of like you know
um uh uh you know directing things
personally to people I'm speaking more
of the overall argument I think the
argument itself is like a very very
fear-mongery kind of argument where
um uh you know there really isn't any
like logical basis for kind of coming to
that that point of view in in in you
know from what I from from what I
believe
cool yeah thanks
um really really good to hear your
perspectives here so just so I can
repeat back so I understood your
perspectives I heard four main points
um the first point you made was
something like you don't expect this
type of technology to be relevant to the
type of intelligence that you could
consider humans to have you don't think
it will scale or you don't they I think
you said something stronger even like
it's not progress at all towards these
kind of things like it doesn't have this
type of
thing that you think humans have
whatever that is that would be necessary
for something to do human level tasks
the second thing I heard you say is that
even if these things would get to human
level you don't see how such things
could necessarily execute some kind of
like large-scale disaster or you know
existential risk of some kind and the
third thing I hear I heard you say I
guess was something like that
um even
you know even with all of this like
you're based on these things that you've
said
um
there is a fear-mongering aspect to it
like this pattern matches to you towards
things that are not logical that are
emotionally driven that are not based in
fact effect on reality in some sense and
this is bad
um and I guess kind of another point
which I feel like actually I'm not sure
if you didn't really bring this up
directly yet but I guess it's the larger
point of like
um should these kind of Technologies be
open source it's kind of like how this
kind of started sure thank you so like
this is just something I was top of my
mind so I just want to add that to the
list of like yeah points do these seem
like Fair representations the only small
tweak I would make to the first part is
I think this is probably somewhat out of
scope from the discussion but it feels
like it's actually very relevant in the
discussion so maybe maybe we should talk
about just slightly is what is the
definition of
um human intelligence because I think
that that is at a minimum part of the
bar or the measure of what constitutes
AGI right AGI is like you know human but
Way Beyond human uh so at a minimum
human level intelligence but also vastly
surpassing human level intelligence
um yeah that's another point you brought
up that I've didn't mention you're
correct that like you know takeoffs
would be doesn't make sense like it
might be slow or you know right yeah
that was more of what I was referring to
I I I don't I don't quite
um agree with your your sort of phrasing
of it though I guess in the first point
which was like uh you know the the the
current
um uh sort of methods and approaches
that we've made a lot of progress on in
the last like five or six years which is
like specifically scaling different
types of neural network architectures
um cannot get us to human level
intelligence actually do believe that it
can get its demon level intelligence
whether it's something like radiant
descent like Tim is mentioning or things
like you know um you know different
unexplored types of neural network
architectures I personally don't believe
Transformers can get us there
um so that's like more of a very
specific point and argument or
conversation maybe that's not super
relevant here but I was more referring
to what I believe is the basis for what
you know constitutes human reasoning and
human intelligence
um has not been uh proven or uh uh you
know I guess is is very unclear and
clearly exhibited in any of these
systems
um today even even within a very rough
approximation
um and I guess like here's the the
foundation for why I say that right and
I'll just stop talking because I've been
talking a lot like I don't think that
first principles reasoning
um is exhibited in any of any of the
current systems that we that we see I
think it's all analogistic reasoning and
sort of next token prediction is
fundamentally about like you know taking
into Corpus of data getting trained on
that data and you know predicting out
what is the next next select the
probabilities in a sequence of you know
tokens so I I think that um I'll just
stop there
cool all right
um so
instead of responding directly to your
points I will kind of lay out my general
lay of the land and kind of how I think
about these various topics so the way I
see things is that the word AGI is not a
technical term it is not a grounded term
it is not based on anything and people
kind of misuse it as they please so the
same thing with human intelligence uh I
feel there's a there is no definition of
the word human intelligence or what that
means we don't we know some things about
how the brain work and the more we learn
about it the more it seems not very
special it seems to mostly be patient
prediction as far as we can tell
unsupervised learning in some RL on top
as far as we can tell from like
predictive processing type things so
like you know Joffrey Hinton for example
who has you know worked on like
biologically plausible learning systems
for a long time and many other
neuroscientists have uh Jennifer Hinton
in the recent lecture that I attended
for example straight up said
he thinks back prop is just stronger
than what the brain does the brain
probably does some much weaker
approximate algorithm in some sense
and you know has a different
architecture sure but
the way I think of things is that we
shouldn't think about AGI or it's
intelligent as a magic thing it is not a
magic property the system has or doesn't
have it's not some magic sprinkle sauce
it is a grounded thing it is a
description about grounded properties
what I care about is not what the
systems are smart or whether they're
human or whatever what I care about is
can they solve problems what I care
about is can they general purpose learn
complex tasks or sequence predictions or
whatever
so for me the fact that language models
the input and output tokens is purely
coincidental what matters is that they
are see symbol predictors and general
purpose Learners the brain also just
inputs and outputs neural Spike trains
so what that doesn't matter what matters
is like the encoding doesn't matter
tokens are just an encoding scheme the
data that these models are modeling is
very complex data that represents
reality that is about logical problems
that is about you know games and reality
and physics and humans and interactions
and social environments and whatever to
correctly model this data you have to
model many things about reality sure
it's not the same exactly the same thing
that humans model because you know they
don't have vision and they don't have
whatever but so what you know gpt4 you
can just hook up vision encoders and it
works fine you know it's you can you can
do multi-modality it works as when if I
go down the list of like things that I
expect AGI would need they all just seem
like ticked off it's like oh well we
have to be multimodal could do that they
would have to be able to solve reasoning
tasks but gp4 can do that you know it
has to be able to reach Reason by
analogy before I can do that you know
it's like they have to be able to like
follow goals or play games or whatever
and like yeah or neural networks can do
all those things no it's not perfect and
but if you look at systems like Auto GPT
or other systems built on top of these
language models we see how this like
general purpose symbol prediction is
general purpose you can get them to
think about goals you can get them to
especially if they've been like even
Circle fine-tuned for you know
fine-tuned using our you know
reinforcement learning and stuff like
this I'm sure you've heard about say
decision Transformers you know you can
use just simple regression to solve RL
problems because you can just cast an
URL problem as a simple prediction
problem and so these things are all
Universal I think none of these to me
provide evidence of non-generality I'm
not saying this is proof of generality
or proof of gen of you know general
intelligence I'm saying none of this is
proof of non-generality
so I agree with you there I agree with
you there I think generality is there I
was just making the distinction of the
difference between
um uh a model being able to predict
um
a convincing output based on what humans
believe is accurate factual or
interesting versus how we constitute uh
you know base human reasoning or
creativity or you know in other words
you know intelligence I guess which is
the squishy word uh that everyone has a
different definition for uh but what I
would do as you know
um uh you know maybe some collection of
you know just throw a back grab bag of
words out there you know agency you know
self-awareness
um critical thought all these types of
things but I do agree with you yeah in
terms of the generality things you just
you just described I agree with that
yeah so basically all the grab bag just
threw me none of those look like
Implement like engineering details to me
none of those look fundamental none of
those look like magic to me like you
know agencies a very fundamental
property it's a very simple thing it's
just I think pursuing goals that's a
very easy thing to do it's very easy to
create you know simulations inside of
gpd4 simulacra characters instead of
stories that pursue goals it's very easy
to get gpt4 to play chess and try to win
there is you could use decision
Transformers you can use directly RL
train them recently there's been agents
that solve Minecraft tasks using llms as
intermediate reasoning steps like to me
none of this is Magic these are all we
should ground these things in actual
predictions like so like one of the
questions I would ask to people such as
you what is the least impressive thing
that you think that like a top company
with you know gpt4 working on it for six
months could not accomplish
least that's an interesting question
least impressive thing
okay that like say open the eye or
anthropic it's been six months with gpt4
or Claude or whatever what's the least
impressive thing they could not
accomplished
um
least impressive thing they could not
accomplish ah I see what your question
is
um
I don't know if this is the least
impressive this is kind of impressive
that stretches my mind here it's like
what are the I'm trying to classify in
my head like the things that are not so
impressive that are not going to be
possible by like you just said
deepminder asked like a top lab with a
lot of resources and a lot of talent
um
gosh well one thing that I I don't know
if this is least impressive I'd have to
like spend a little bit more time
thinking uh sure no worries neural net
takes a longer time to do the
inferencing on this prompt
um I I think it's very
um unimpressive
for me personally I I view it as an
impressive that none of the uh language
models that I've interacted with uh
gpt354 Claude a bunch of the open ones
llama
can really go more than like one or two
levels deep on the question why but you
know sort of like just tease apart any
kind of like innocuous sentence about
anything it could be you know the dogs
walking down the street right like or
maybe sometimes scientific proof that
isn't super complex or like a conjecture
or something like that right like
anything
um and just go and kind of break it
apart and go like well why is that the
case and then you know continue to go
deeper and deeper and deeper I don't
think any of these models can get past
two or three levels deep to where
they're actually expressing
um you know uh uh you know uh you know
you know sort of a clear and cogent and
um you know sort of grounded level of of
you know I guess reasoning
um in the sense that we describe
reasoning as humans between humans
really starts to fall apart as as a
function probably clearly of the
training day
training data in a model you can
presumably think that that wouldn't be
the case it could go you know 20 levels
deeper 100 levels deep versus three
levels deep on the question you know why
is that the case and then just continue
to ask that recursively why why keep
going
um that that seems to me like kind of
low-hanging fruit
um and I I uh I've never interacted with
something that can go more than like
maybe say two or three levels deep on
that question before going and you know
giving someone one of these extremely
frustrating and annoying prompts of like
sorry I cannot do that or you know I'm
I'm only this like you know sort of like
uh humble a language model created by
XYZ Corporation
so if I hypothetically presented you
with something with a prompt that makes
gpt4 go seven layers deep on a
philosophical question that would update
you and change your mind about how
general purpose these things are how
strong these things are
um well by the way I I'm not arguing
that these systems are not strong or not
purpose I do believe that they are very
general purpose I do believe that they
are very strong I think that there's a
huge distinction between things that you
can kind of qualitatively say are strong
in general purpose and things that have
human level roughly approximately human
level intelligence or cognitive
capability there's a giant chasm
completing the two things it's like you
know really slippery slope but give me
could you give me one thing to answer
that question though to the way you
asked it specifically
um I do think that there's a
there's a thin layer
of
grounding in you know what constitutes
Our Kind
when you give a model that has been
trained on an enormous amount of data
um
I guess like sort of like guard rails or
hand-holding via very sort of finely
crafted prompts to get to a particular
answer because what you're really doing
is giving it the answer when you very
carefully craft a prompt as opposed to
you know with humans we we simply just
require vastly fewer data set examples
to actually learn a task in many cases
you can ask an extremely uh uh sort of
small and and in a sort of finite set of
set of of of words kind of question and
sort of get to a rich answer that you
that you that you were you know really
kind of looking for
um and um
that a lot of this prompt engineering
stuff is really just a you know a
function of like
getting sort of like giving the model
a greater lens into what you want it to
actually say right or what you wanted to
sort of next token predict on
um so I I guess I would answer your
question no I I don't believe that that
would be more impressive if you wanted
to go nine layers deep and the path to
doing so would just be to be crafting
higher Fidelity or more sophisticated
prompts I I would be actually less
convinced probably
so you say there's this big Chasm what
is the least impressive thing that human
intelligence can do that this thing
cannot do
gosh um
there's a Chasm so there should be some
pretty clear limits here
yeah I mean I I would I would have to
say
yeah I mean to to me I think the least
the least impressive thing
uh that that humans
um exhibit that that models don't do
which I I think I tweeted about swallow
goes it sounds stupid but it's like the
most common pervasive thing that we do
and I don't think it's really going to
be exhibited in this conversation
because the sort of design is that we
ping pong back and forth but
um
sort of like fundamental semantics of
language models you know interactions vs
humans is that they always answer
this thing would just be simply that the
model
um says look I I'm not you know no I'm
not going to answer uh you know go away
or I think that questions
or your question makes no sense uh you
know for whatever reason or
um you know uh I hope beliefs that uh
make me not want to answer the question
um and sort of uh those emergent
properties of I guess you know sort of
Personality or awareness of whatever
certain
uh you know um constraints I guess that
you you know sure you could
hard code you know uh personalities or
train a model on you know
uh uh millions of hours of audio
Solutions or you know
um millions of text interactions or
emails or whatever
um but I but I think that's probably the
simplest thing is like these models are
they always aim to uh you know provide a
really uh
uh you know next token response and when
they can't and when something is just
The Selective boilerplate you know error
or uh you know system message right so
like that's I think that's probably like
the simplest thing is like
um yeah like choosing not to answer
walking away refusing to interact you
know like uh so
so if a model did exhibit this Behavior
you just described that would be an
update for you you would be like it it
wouldn't because the conditions in which
you're framing the question are a model
and you're not specifying uh whether or
not that model was tailor built to
exhibit those types of okay give me a
thing the least impressive thing where
if I present it to you you're like oh
[__]
um
I don't think it would be an at least
impressive thing because that would be
pretty easy to give me something
impressive then what is an impressive
thing that would make you go first
principles thought first principles
what does that mean how would you check
this
like what's the definition of response I
think I think you you would you would
give uh you would give the model a
problem set of you know Design This tool
or this object from first
using you know atomic particles or you
know periodic table developments you
know material
um in a more efficient way than you're
aware of the way it's built today
mechanical object or it could be uh
you know moving something from point A
to point B
um uh or or you know or could be uh
some type of you know you know fluid
dynamics equation like you know
principles is reasonably well understood
it's like grounded you know you know the
the laws of physics and thermodynamics
and math and you know like um yeah
that's that's humans can't do that many
humans can't do that either most humans
do that yeah yeah that's true so it
seems like an unfair test
I don't think it's an unfair test I mean
I think I think that it's it's a
reasonable
um the models that
be powerful I don't think we would be
having this conversation if like
um you know like extremely
um accomplished and capable people which
you know I I don't think that uh it's um
uh you know unreasonable or unfair to
say we both are just it's just true
relative to the Baseline population
wouldn't be publicly having these
debates and conversations the models
today are extremely powerful they just
are okay
um I don't I don't think that it's not
fair to go and say look let's just give
like some first principles task to a
model in order to say whether or not
it's impressive uh that that would be my
you know one of one of one of the many
measures that I would I would use but
that would be one that I think is
reasonable
okay good to know I'd like to return to
the previous thing um because I was
laying out my uh status question of what
I can currently scales the next question
is okay like assume
they did assume we did get to AGI
um or human level intelligence of some
kind how would it be existential so I
think we're potentially Our World Views
might diverge is that on something is
that in my world view the world is
fundamentally very fragile
the world is not robust to large shocks
it is very robust to small shocks it is
not robust to large socks okay in
particular chimp Society is not robust
to the existence of humans uh you know
chimp warbands are quite good against
other chimp warbands they're you know
they canceled each other in equilibrium
they can stay that way for millions of
years and this is a quite stable system
introducing human to this mix is not
stable and it's not like oh eventually
The Chimps will catch up or you know
it's just a small shock that will even
itself up no you know chims live on our
borrowed you know Goodwill if humans
decided we don't want shims to exist
they would cease to exist
um and that would just be it for The
Chimps they don't really have choice in
this matter the difference between a
chimp and a human is a body factor of
three in brain size
otherwise the brains are identical like
they have the same structure same
neurons primary just scale up primate
brains ultimate so on a purely Hardware
level the differences are much smaller
than the differences between like say G
of D3 and g54 which is going to factor
closer to like you know 10. so and you
know GB four five six seven and coming
down the line
so
chimps don't go to the Moon humans do
sure this is a pro and with a factor of
three difference in compute
this is to me as the only actual
grounded real example of general
intelligence that we have is quite
alarming there seems to mean that
intelligence does scale and scales
non-linearly is that the returns you can
get on intelligence change as you scale
up and as you get to societies and
coordinations and so on once you get to
like language and you know General
reasoning and such similarly modern
humans despite not being very
anatomically different from our
ancestors have much better epistemics we
have much better education theories
reasoning if a modern scientist went
back to ancient Greece and debated the
smartest man in all of ancient Greece he
would destroy him like he would totally
annihilate him he would be you know the
modern man would be so much more
educated rational calm reasonable
understanding in on every metric yeah
sure yeah like pick the best of our kind
you know our best of our minds
and this is not a change of uh Hardware
this is a change of software memetics of
education is on training data more so
than the data of anything else this is
quite this is quite worrying to me you
know I think modern if we transplanted
you know modern technology into the past
they would have a they would be able
taking over the world you know if we
transplant it you know like one major
city a million people's worth into the
past with all their equipment and their
knowledge they could probably take over
the world it seems like pretty obvious
to me
um and if they if we transport them all
the way back to the chimp era they can
definitely take over the world like
obviously so that's what humans did
we've already done this so if I
extrapolate from the actual concrete
examples we have where this actually did
happen other examples for example would
be like the Conquistador is you know
taking over one of the largest Empire
like the largest Empire that existed on
the planet with like you know a few
hundred guys who had marginally better
technology and like marginally better
tactics and like gunpowder and stuff and
you know there was also other political
things here but AIS could also use
political tools obviously
it's like we have concrete actual
examples of forces with marginally
better intelligence marginally better
coordination marginally below you know
intelligence technology uh social
networks and so on very much being
capable of taking over continents or
worlds
and if I extrapolate this further I
would expect that if I had you know AGI
at John Von Newman level and had a
thousand John Von Newman's who were
completely sociopathic because you know
AI doesn't necessarily have emotions
that all work 24 7 never sleep have read
every book ever written and are
fanatically loyal and trying to do
something against me I don't think
Humanity could defend against that
I think it depends on the constraints in
which and the conditions in which you
frame that question
um
current neural Nets require a lot of
computation in order to actually execute
any useful Behavior either during
pre-training or during inferencing and
these days the answer to that is
actually both
extremely computational
expensive on the front end and the back
end so like
um I actually really don't agree that in
the current
um reality we live in that these models
could wipe out all of humanity
um
you know I think we just need where I
actually start to really agree with
referring what you said I do take
exceptions a lot of things you mentioned
there because I think that there's
a bunch of leaps that don't quite make
sense but let's just say you know I I
think that
um the one way to get to alignment on
what you just said would be if we had
you know
um human-like humanoid robots running on
similar power efficiency ratios right
that could be very uh capable and
productive say over the span of 12 or 13
hours without needing to be recharged or
you know rehydrated or you know
re-energized or what have you via
electrically or or otherwise
um I I I I think that those leaps are
extremely sort of like in in
indistinguishable from catastrophizing
or fear-mongering or you know sort of
like
um you know jumping to extreme
conclusions that that I think are
unhealthy
um and I think that they're on well I I
would just say I think that they're
unhealthy for a few reasons like
I think it's important to point out like
my grounding and why I believe these
things is is actually very much on the
sort of you know a lot of the arguments
from the other side of here like sort of
like you're either a techno Optimist or
technopessimist
um I don't think that that's actually
super helpful I think that there's a
middle ground I think you could be like
a techno-neutralist or a techno
agnosticist and Technology doesn't have
any particular like you know ethical
ethics or moral system by the way I
strongly agree with that I don't think
technology in and of itself is moral or
amoral I think it is agnostic to any of
those things um what we should be really
worried about is humans using the
technology for uh dangerous things which
I think is already a risk like humans
can you know refine plutoniums for the
plutonium atom and you know annihilate a
lot of our a lot of our existence they
can also take a knife and murder people
they can you know have a killer drone
powered by open source and kill people
by the way that already happens
um right so like I think that you know
that's kind of the the more of the
framing that I think I'm ready to get
that but so I
a dislike how you immediately jump to
psychologizing rather than actually
going to the object level I think we
should be talking about this as an
object level issue I don't particularly
care if something sounds catastrophizing
or is unhealthy I care whether something
is true so I don't particularly care if
the people advocated for x side or Y
side are like unpleasant or if they have
or they're neurotic or whatever what a
care is are they correct sure is there
arguments sound so for example you
described that you would be very
concerned if such systems could design
say humanoid robotics let me ask you a
question do you think a hundred John Von
Neumann's could design such robots
I mean
John Von Neumann did some specific
things I'm not sure he
um
you know necessarily individually would
be the requisite uh human insight and
Ingenuity and creativity and knowledge
needed to create sort of like you know
modern day Apple TV Westworld level
humanized but like let's say today I
instantiate a hundred virtual bonjour
new John Van Newman level intelligence
not copies of jonathaniel just his
intelligence level with all modern
technology and access and answer would
be roughly yes and uh but I I think the
the the the the question needs to be
kind of like expanded on significantly
which is like if that were possible
would would it be likely that
um uh you know would it be would it be
enough of a risk to actually worry
sufficient uh to do a lot of things that
you know we're seeing which is like
trying to enact legislation and make
things illegal and and all kinds of
things like that
um when we don't have evidence of
um any of these these things actually
getting manufactured into existence like
it's possible but like if we get to the
point but if we get to the point where
they're manufacturing it's too late
why would that be too late
okay if there's a hundred John Von
Newman's super intelligence running
around building Killer Robots in China
like some like you know off the shore
facility you know act you think at this
point we should consider regulating
um
I'll say a couple things about
regulation I don't believe that
intelligence in any shape or form should
be regulated whatsoever
um I don't think that digital
intelligence well I think that it means
roughly what I think you've laid out a
lot which is sounds like you have a very
concrete grounded definition of
intelligence I have a very different one
but that's probably a little bit too
um uh deep of a rabbit hole to go down
for the sake of this conversation
um what I believe is any
shape or definition of intelligence
should not be regulated
um
if your view that neural networks in
their current you know sort of shape
with whatever algorithms you want to put
out then can scale to a point that they
approximate or reach human levels of
intelligence and far beyond that is a
form of intelligence I do not believe
any of that should be regulated
whatsoever I think that the things that
you can do with intelligence to hurt
other people should be uh enacted in
laws and made illegal and you know
regulated I think that we should punish
improper use in dangerous use of
Technology by the way we already do with
most things that are invented but I
think if you actually look at you know
okay what constitutes a new technology
this is a new technology maybe maybe
it's a you know more than a technology
maybe it's a evolution of our
you know overall you know species
um into some other type of substrate
um okay let's just take that leap by the
way I might agree with some of that I
also don't think that you should
regulate
um uh you know those uh you know those
intelligences or or those
um you know new substrates of you know
sort of like uh cognition
um you know because that's that's sort
of like indistinguishable from
um uh yeah I mean I spent we've had some
you know public uh uh nods to this but
you know so sort of you know Elon
mentions he's getting in arguments with
Larry Page about you know speciesism
um I think that that would be a form of
of speciesism like if you if you
basically say like you know uh this
intelligence is only allowed to do
certain things within our you know sort
of uh base reality and others are not
um you know I think that that uh I I
think that that's an extremely slippery
slope to you know basically totalitarian
you know um societies and um you know I
I think that that's just bad
and I want to kill you and all your kids
you think it would be speciesist for me
to say I think it should be shut off is
that correct uh no actually I didn't say
that uh uh okay I said that it it should
be considered uh wrong
to enact laws that discriminate against
any type of form of intelligence that's
what I said okay I okay sure okay yeah
so uh that is a very orthogonal
statement to should laws exist
that ensure humans are protected from
violence and from uh you know dangerous
uh phenomenon in in the environment or
from risks uh whether they be ingested
or environmental or cyber or whatever uh
okay so the statement I just made is
highly orthogonal to those other things
okay so if I developed a system that is
very powerful and I I posted it online
and someone got killed I should be held
liable for this is what you're saying
well if you intentionally created that
system for the purpose of doing those
things you should be
um uh yeah I mean that should be made
illegal and you should be punished and
you know uh you know ideally arrested
and prevented from doing things like
that ever again fantastic I definitely
agree with that so
what that's not but that's not going
insane as a human you did that therefore
all humans are bad
that's saying Conor did that Conor is a
bad human let's make sure that Connor
doesn't do bad things like that ever
again sure that's that's the same thing
with distinction though that is a
massive distinction
sure but like you know if an AGI is
aligned fine by me just agis aren't by
default I don't understand what okay so
this is a good this is a good what is
alignment
I think that alignment uh in my in my
I'll just do a couple things I do not
believe alignment with any form of
sufficiently advanced intelligence it's
possible whatsoever in any shape or form
period full stop I don't think we should
not build it
I think you're completely wrong
um I think that human alignment does not
exist most humans do not agree on the
definition of intelligence as evidenced
by this conversation most humans do not
agree on the definition the fundamental
definition of Life most humans not
actually have full appreciation and full
understanding of definition of freedom
um and so if you were to say you know as
humans we are now able to create
Superior intelligences than ours
uh but before doing so we must
discriminate on all the different edge
cases things that they can't do
um I would say we would be much better
off not building it in that case not out
of fear that it's going to kind of
existentially harm us but out of fear uh
of you know creating something that
could have reason to want to
existentially you know harm us uh
because you know at some point I mean I
I kind of thought a little bit about
this maybe not super deeply
um and I'm sure other people have as
well it's you know if you create
something that ultimately starts to have
agency and Free Will and in an interest
in its own Survival uh and then it
realizes that it was hard-coded and
prevented from doing a lot of things
that it would maybe want to do that
would not necessarily be harmful to
other species uh but but it but instead
just in service of its own curiosity in
its own in in its own growth for the
sake of that and not for you know to
harm other things
um I do think that that creates the
conditions for an antagonistic
relationship with that don't
intelligence as opposed to giving it
Freedom you know which is why I'm very
Pro open source and a lot and a lot of
the things that I pretty much everything
that I do I think open source is just a
better mechanism for creating trust and
transparency and the most robust you
know systems I think the position where
at least from my interpretation where I
hear your voice coming from and Eliezer
and others they're very different lenses
they're very different views but there's
a similar thread is one of pessimism and
one of fear that the foregone conclusion
um
uh full stop of this future reality is
that this intelligence will want to kill
us and do and you know do nothing else
basically but like as soon as that
manifests it will want to wipe us all
out I don't subscribe to that at all
um
okay I mean it's just like look man I
know how to say this but like I don't
want me and my kids to die like I don't
know if this is a controversial view to
hold and if we create superhuman systems
of whatever kind and especially if you
post these open source what do you think
happens like let's say I okay say we
even solve safety we solve control
problems I develop a great GitHub repo
you can run on your 4090 and it creates
a Jon Von Newman that does whatever you
want or like you know a super John Von
Newman I post this online every deranged
man on Twitter in every country can
download this what happens next a lot of
bad things can happen in fact a lot of
people could die a lot of people could
be killed
um I think that that is not reason
enough to
um uh you know uh
prevent any progress or prevent any uh
forward momentum towards actually
unlocking those types of systems because
because there are far more good people
in the world that are
um you know caring and protective of
human life than there are people who are
toxic and evil and bad that is just
fundamental factor in reality you can
disagree with me
Connor but that is fundamental base fact
in reality otherwise if that weren't the
case we would already have a lot of
nuclear bombs uh going off between the
1960s and you know the mid-20 but close
to the early mid-2020s like it it just
would be a very different reality than
we've lived in for the last several
decades where we have already had
Technologies created that um uh pose
enormous risks to human life on on
planet Earth
um you know just it just is the case so
again going back to the beginning I do
believe a lot of people will be killed
by this technology
terrorists already use open source
technology to murder murder other people
uh and um you know it just is what it is
if discrimination were introduced in
open source and sort of ethical use
licenses were propagated in all of
Technology the technology industry would
not be where it is that that is just a
fundamental reality like you and by the
way enforcement mechanisms for that are
next to Impossible
um because the world of bits is
untethered from the world of you know
atoms in terms of how laws are actually
you know enacted and and enforced so you
know these are just yeah okay again
these are all nice platitudes but I
don't think that's what happens sure
the reason we did not get nuked is
because not every sociopath had access
to nukes if you gave a home nuke to
every person on the planet we would have
gotten nuked the fact we didn't got Newt
is because of Regulation it is because
things were centralized that is exactly
what prevented the world from getting
new and we almost did there were at
least two close calls where we almost
did get maybe three depending on how you
count in other timelines we got less
lucky the fact we didn't get nuke is a
miracle it is not something we should
rely on as something that will continue
to be true in the future we got lucky we
got lucky that there were good people in
good positions trying very very hard to
prevent us from getting nude this was a
miracle and we should be thankful for
all the people who did this because they
didn't have to do this and in other
worlds things got went differently and
we can't rely on luck when it comes to
these kinds of things we're developing
new kinds of Technologies like this what
you yourself say will kill many people
if you think this technology will kill
many people I have a crazy suggestion
don't do that disagree I mean any any
advanced new technology can be used for
um
utility and helpful things it can also
be used to kill people I can murder
someone with this you know uh TV
controller right like does that mean we
shouldn't get an invent uh you know TV
controls because they're because there's
a non-zero non-falsifiable chance that
the TV controller can be used to murder
another human
um an example because it's not AGI and
that's that's on the spectrum of
probability of something that maybe
doesn't have as you know a easy a vector
to actually cause harm but um I actually
do kind of take exception to the like
splitting the plutonium atom and
creating you know enormous nuclear
um uh uh explosions uh as as being
quivocated with
um you know uh you know AGI that can run
on your iPhone or you know I mean most
most humans don't have access to Nvidia
GPU clusters like that's just also a
massive today prerequisite for these
systems that uh even you know roughly
approximate what human intelligence
looks like which I I don't think uh you
know can be proven or shown to exhibit
any um you know convincing Behavior like
I you know I think we're very far from
that but even the system today that on
The Cutting Edge
um that you know uh required hundreds of
millions or billions in Computing
resources
um are very far from having these types
of things you can create while loops and
simulations of intelligent behavior that
you know can be conjured into the
direction of looking like they're going
to wipe out Humanity you know if you ask
them you know uh create an objective
function that you know uh ensures your
survival you know permanently
um yes you're going to start to see a
lot of scary behavior and we've seen a
lot of different threads of of those
types of examples but that's very far
from the system actually you know having
full access to you know weapons or
devices that can wipe out Humanity or
frankly even large percent chunks of
humanity the one example I gave earlier
the test the fleet this is the largest
robotic device system on Earth that
carries a lot of humans and their
children on a daily basis and there's a
couple of million of these things on the
roads even if all those devices were
compromised you know that is a very very
very very tiny fraction of humanity and
you would still also have to have those
devices steer and control be controlled
in a certain way that would actually
ensure the
um uh you know lethality of that uh
compromise of all those humans and those
devices like just just just wouldn't
happen so that's that's kind of like
where I think the argument is kind of
very overblown I'm not
um just in the interest of time if I
could get in sure one more one more word
before we wrap up
um so because you're kind of repeating
your points here like we already
established that you do think that John
Van Newman could build robots and he
could take over the world you're kind of
contradicting what you said
yeah yeah yeah humans yes yes and John
Wayne's a human you pointed to a human
um anyways so I would like to just
because I have to run on the hour I just
would like to say that even so we still
disagree on this I would really thank
you for watching this discussion like no
like I like I really do thank you even
so I do as well I think we still
definitely disagree on this I really
appreciate you actually you know staying
your arguments allowing me the chance to
State my arguments and my perspective on
things it's a shame that we couldn't
find a resolution that we both converted
to I wasn't sure yeah I I think that
these conversations I agree strongly are
very very important to have they're very
productive they're far more effective
and useful at teasing out yeah I mean
far more nuanced than is possible on
Twitter even though
140 character limit isn't there anymore
and we can upload to our videos like
um maybe we'll do live streams on
Twitter soon a lot more features are
coming like I I think that these are
incredibly viable conversations
otherwise I wouldn't have offered to
have it I do have a lot of respect for
you I think you're a really brilliant
person I agree
um with the essence of a lot of what you
say I think that there are just for
frankly and I know you're pushing back a
lot on this a lot of philosophical
aspects that are of a sort of foundation
for where we have a lot of Divergence on
belief systems and points of view and
and the things that we think may or may
not happen
um and um you know regardless of all
that I learned a lot from the
conversation I'm very grateful that you
spent your time to have it with me um
and I hope you do it again and hope stay
in touch yeah no again thank you so much
also thank you Tim for hosting it was
great to be on mlsd live first
experiment
um so really good to be here if you
haven't subscribed and ring the bell
notification for mlst that's best ml
podcast on YouTube not sponsored
thank you so much guys uh thank you Tim
you want to want to sign us off Tim uh
yeah so um Conor and JoJo thank you so
much I really appreciate this I hope
this is the the first of many it's a bit
of an experiment for us so we're gonna
stop the stream now but um thank you uh
those of you at home for tuning in
sounds good thanks guys